[Music]
uh you know our two guests tonight from
one of the longest running science
fiction television shows of all time
ladies and gentlemen a big Calgary
welcome from Michael Shanks and Richard
Dean Anderson
[Applause]
[Music]
so we have got our starving panel today
so I want you to put your hands together
for Amanda Tapping and Richard Dean
Anderson
thank you
[Applause]
so guys do you want to talk about uh
maybe Stargate
that little thing you did for the better
part of two decades
[Laughter]
um yeah let's talk about that stuff
let's do that we could talk about a lot
of stuff we could talk about the economy
and you know
yeah exactly you know asking us to just
you know Free Speech free talk about our
old series I did have some specific
questions okay let's do that don't
interrupt me while I'm talking
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
isn't that awesome but also bring how
much science you actually picked up
using all that techno bubble in the
episodes or whether or not it is all
just absolutely versatile to you a
little bit no no I I always like to get
really seriously so I studied it and and
then what I did was I broke it down at
the layman's terms so I can explain it
everybody
so I can explain it to my husband and
then I thought if he could understand it
then I've got it so I don't know
uh but I broke it down into layman's
terms so I fully understood what I was
doing and I understood I understood the
Techno battle I was very proud of the
fact that I understand
could I blow up the sun right now no
there was a dynamic on the show I don't
know if you noticed
um where and first of all they had sense
enough to give
Michael and Amanda all the dialogue are
the Mainstay anyway and I was relegated
to the reactionary
what
and which kind of helped the dynamic a
lot but there's no way we could do it
any other way I could memorize that
dialogue to save my life and she could
she thank God thank God you're on that
show
it's a slash fiction reference
what that uh you and uh Samantha Carter
never hooked up in the show
are you sure
well not on a long-term alternate
reality basis but uh you watch the show
I do
so never officially but um I wanted to
ask there's of course videos of YouTube
of some great things that have happened
on set including when ataps did the
whole stuck on a glacier with MacGyver
thing and I was wondering if you guys
have stories of like your favorite
pranks that were pulled on you or that
you pulled on others did you just call
Amanda eight taps
I'm from the internet at Peru hey baby
that's far out I guess what would that
make you trying to trying to find Rick
Rick dunnons
well my name backwards is NOS Redna
that's Anderson backwards
look it up try and keep up folks
because I can't
sorry what was that question again
just say it again
um yeah a
you guys did you have favorite pranks
that you guys pulled on others or that
were pulled on you
yeah not really no
you know I don't
I don't believe I don't know what
happened after I left but we
nothing yeah nothing happened after you
left
thank you so much
um
it's a Ben Browder
joke
um
I don't fancy myself anyway and I didn't
see any formal prankstering it's it was
all just kind of a light attitude about
work and life and things like that and
you know it's if you can't
laugh or
you know smile or be comfortable at work
it's not worth it so
I
just all the unemployed it's like
it's like you just made bogey or
something like that yay way to go
eight Taps huh
I have a question for all of the
shippers
[Laughter]
I'm 70 you know
[Music]
[Applause]
you're only 70. if the starving and the
shipper found them in particular could
have their Canon confirmation Moment
Like The X-Files did after 20 years what
would you like it to be
you're like
so it would be an exterior shot of
Jack's cabin as the sun's coming up
and then cut inside and see Jack and
then Sam would roll over and there
should be all of a sudden on the same
pillow and then they didn't go fishing
hey sorry I'm a little nervous thank you
so much for coming and taking time out
of your schedules my question is what
was the best experience that you had not
necessarily anything that was funny but
something that affected you that you
took away from it oh
um well we can well I'll speak for
myself but I had a baby in Vancouver so
that was
I yes obviously I didn't have a baby
myself but I
had
um uh I was a partner in having a kid
who I still have to this day
and so did you
not the same one it was different
different we do like to recycle yeah
yeah
we don't
our our daughters are actually eight
days apart and what was really funny is
that you know we had the moon in the
second season of the show and now we
haven't seen each other in what four
four years or something we had three
years something like that and um we can
now you know
conciliate with each other over the fact
that they're now teenagers they're now
both 14 and just obtained in the yes
all you 14 year old girls out there
relax
just a little bit it's all going to be
okay it gets better yes
what started I think very quickly was
that they realized that and I think he
said it and you agreed to take on the
part if I recalling you'd said I'm not
going to play this chart and I want to
play somebody with a sense of humor
right sorry but yeah there was a lot
about like early on from Rick and I'm
the rest of us were too scared to admit
but it was his show so good and and that
sort of led us
I don't think I was your boss and it
wasn't my show
I shared it felt like that
um
there was a lot of stuff that happened
and then that sort of like Rick really
paved the way to make the show a lot I
think a lot more accessible because of
its sense of humor
um because even in the most dire
situation like you know you ended that
sentence with a damn clean participle
you bastard things like that it was just
like that's enough
but
the hardest part was keeping
keeping a straight face while you were
you know well there was a nice
transformation that took place our
transitioned
um in tone as the years where the
episodes went by
um
to go back even a step further we used
to have the luxury of a table read
forever script
and it didn't last very long because it
took time nobody was around
yeah and
um but it kind of fell apart after a
conversation that Brad Wright had with
me after one of those table reads until
June
you know a number of ratties right yeah
he's he's your boss
but head writer and we'd go through
these table reads and it's the first
time we're seeing the script so it to me
those are just Little Seeds for you know
to go somewhere else the impulses are
all there on a fresh Peak anyway
stop my brain
um so during the table reads I I would
be living on you know and this is a
fresh script
and Brad took me aside you know and most
of it was getting laughs and what it
didn't matter I wasn't reading the words
the way they were written
so Brad took me aside
um and took me to news office like the
principal and said uh you know you're
you're not doing the writers a great
service by doing what you're doing in
those rehearsals
every one of us works hard to write
these scripts and when we first hear
them you you guys read them we like to
hear the words and he basically he
chastised the hell out of it which I
deserved and I I told him you're right I
said you're right and it occurred to me
that
I should be showing some more respect
for writers who to this day I would be
suspecting most out of the whole process
so
um from that point on it was
we kind of stopped having those
rehearsals but we also I also was I
tried to be a lot more true to the word
on the written page but with the caveat
and this is the agreement I made with
signed in Blood and Brad is that
we do our rehearsal and then we'll find
our moments of levity and you know I'll
always call up or you know clear up with
you
stop me I'm talking it's just honest
okay but uh but that was basically the
the Genesis of
the life
but what happened though with with all
that the the other actors started to do
the same thing
and it really made for
some terrible episodes
so I'm going to ask the obvious question
what was your favorite Stargate villain
Jack O'Neill
[Laughter]
[Applause]
bad guys oh yeah your favorite was
hathor I thought you said Bad actors
and you said Richard Dean Anderson or
Jack O'Neill
what did you say we'll be right back
after this work
that's they're asking asking who our
favorite bad guys are on the show like
oh name a few hathor
two separate people okay yeah I thought
one was an adjective or a verb
uh Anubis
okay uh our first one um
office Apophis
any others
who Anubis
we
I could I could list off some of the
Lesser ones but you don't stand the
chance so I'm just gonna go I'm gonna go
over the big ones I don't think I stand
a chance at this level
um do you have a favorite well you went
as half or yeah yeah I had a good time
with hathor because she was such good
fun it was a fun
it's a morbid sense of fun that I had
with her
she was such a pain in the butt
no no no she wasn't she was actually
quite
um stacked
you 14 year olds
it gets better
thank you
I was the first to break and then I'd
have tears streaming down my face
one of my emphasis I had to spend four
hours
in the morning getting 100 year old
makeup put on
and then two and a half hours to take it
off at the end of the day so
that it was worth that unpleasantry just
to have it on for a few hours during the
day because being an old guy
um is really fun
you can get away with murder
you were a really naughty old no
sorry honey I'm senile
when we're in the water like you know
when the water's rising and all those
kind of like crazy sequences like that
that you think would be really
uncomfortable and Hardware actually
really fun
what's up
you always want to be able to do that as
a kid right
being a situation like that where you're
playing playing and the bad guys are
filling up that tank and you're gonna
drown because you're an actor and you're
in a controlled set you know you're not
going to drown but still you can play it
come on you wouldn't want to do that
again
I remember during the pilot Michael
Shanks and I running beside each other
through the woods with our guns and
[Music]
a second
you were great thank you very much thank
you really great what was the question
[Laughter]
no seriously I can't remember it either
what was it uh if you guys ever got to
oh and the motion I got like emotionally
uh caught up in your character when you
felt like it wasn't really acting
anymore or get me out of the way like
that no
no safe I'm too grounded I'm sorry yep
uh and no no
if you do that I had an acting coach one
time say because I what you're referring
to is like really being in the moment
and I I think
and I told this acting coach I was
playing
um
Othello's uh buddy Iago
why I was playing Iago I'll never know
but
um but I got into this this speech and I
had lost myself for a guy who was so
into it that I didn't it's not me
talking with the acting professor and I
said I was just so
gone I didn't know where I was and I was
just
Iago and I just oh my God and he just
said you got to watch that kind of stuff
because someday you're not going to know
where you are at all Nobody's Gonna Save
You and
um it was a serious note actually
I don't get that deep Michael does he's
a fine actor he's a he's a studied very
fine I saw him do Hamlet
first thing I saw him do in Vancouver
and he was absolutely
just good really
really really good
oh I mean that
but Michael's a real actor come on let's
face it let's see it let's yeah
[Applause]
and I think on our show you'll find if
you really are objective and you look at
all the people who've been on the show
the regulars
um Michael's the only one that really
knew what he was doing as an actor I
mean Amanda was good but she's more of a
comedian and she's got that down Michael
knows what he's doing
I'm jealous prick
I'm getting all teary
um
not really um no uh
I was still stuck on my I still hung up
on my my joke my next joke was like he
says the first thing he saw me in
Vancouver was playing Hamlet he
neglected to to mention the fact that
I'd worked with him for two years on
Stargate just before that happened so
details yes
I'll keep it quick then Mr Anderson
you made the point several times of
adding an L to the O'Neill character's
name when you spelled it out for
reporters was that an ad-lib or was that
something that was required
no
um I didn't ad-lib that that was I think
that was written yeah an actual line
that was written
I said
see I can do it
for it
oh Claire come on invisible
[Laughter]
[Music]
I guess
thank you
I mean MacGyver yeah the guy for
crawling all over you you having your
response
we call it hockey here in Canada
yes yes you do
that's c-l-a-r-e correct okay
I can't I can't even I can't even use
your imagination
enjoy yourself
[Applause]
all right ladies and gentlemen big round
of applause Michael Shanks Richard Dean
Anderson
right there
[Applause]
[Music]